March Madness is upon us.
Duke head coach
Mike Krzyzewski,
is set to retire as perhaps
the greatest college basketball
coach of all time.
And you must acknowledge
his greatness.
REPORTER: The final home game
of Coach Mike Krzyzewski's
Duke coaching career.
This was the entry for the man,
the myth, the legend.
REPORTER 2: 96 former players
came to support him.
Jerry Seinfeld
and NBA commissioner Adam Silver
were among those
in the building.
I don't even know what to say.
It's like part
of my basketball life
is disappearing.
Thank you, Coach K,
and go Duke.
(SCOFFS) Please.
You know what you didn't see
in that video?
A lot of Black people over 35.
We kind of hate that dude.
We hate that he beat
every team Black people loved.
Ten years ago,
if Duke would have played
the Ku Klux Klan,
we would have rooted
for a 0-0 tie.
However, to much of the nation,
Duke basketball was
like venture capital.
Speaking with a manager,
bringing your dog to work.
Symbolic of white excellence,
just like these
excellent white Duke alums,
Richard Nixon, Richard Spencer,
and the man who wears his heart
on his hairline, Stephen Miller.
Coach K brought those excellent
vibes to Durham in 1980.
Just listen to how he talks
about their recruiting.
What Duke does is it gives me--
it limits some of my recruiting
because not every youngster
can get into Duke.
And that doesn't mean that kids
who don't make it at Duke
are worse or better.
It's just that schools are
for different kids.
Doesn't sound like
he was recruiting the kids
from Rosa Parks High School.
Let me be clear,
Coach K's legacy is built on
society's perception
of whiteness,
the idea that
his players overcame
their physical deficiencies,
that they were harder working,
smarter, not as athletic.
Being good made Coach K a star.
Being better than us
made him a legend.
And that's not
Coach K being racist.
But the rest of you...
(CHUCKLES) I don't know.
So let me take it back to 1980.
The rising tide of Blackness
in college basketball
was a threat to the whole game.
That year,
the Louisville Cardinals
won their first championship.
Some people called them
the Blackbirds.
Yes, it only took
a half-Black roster to get
a racist nickname back then.
Not quite the one drop rule,
but damn if it don't
feel the same.
Anyway, soon after,
John Thompson's Georgetown
established itself as a power,
Black power.
Every single player
on their 1984 Championship team
was Black.
If somebody would've
called them the Blackbirds,
I would've understood.
But in 1986,
Duke lost to Louisville
in the National Championship.
Check out how the
Chicago Tribune felt about that.
They really must've thought
Black players couldn't read
if they printed that shit.
I mean, it's not like
white sports fans had nothing
to be proud of.
The best player in the NBA
was Larry Bird.
Quarterbacks were still
supposed to be white.
And the heavyweight champions
of the world were these guys!
But college basketball
seemed on the brink
of eternal darkness.
That's when Coach K pulled up
with the Caucasian Avengers.
And their Captain America
was this guy.
Now, before you say anything,
we're not erasing
Johnny Dawkins, Grant Hill,
and other Black Devils.
But Christian Laettner
was so white,
he got caught
stepping on somebody
and didn't even get thrown out
of the game.
BOBBY HURLEY: It was symbolic
of why some people
didn't like Christian,
you know, in terms of
him willing to cross the line
and do something
a little bit arrogant.
It was just a little love tap
on his chest.
Asshole.
Duke beat every team
Black folks loved
from 1986 to '92.
Georgetown, Arkansas, UNLV.
And the one program that felt
the most like ours,
Michigan's Fab Five.
Look at these
cool motherfuckers.
Black socks, long shorts,
pristine edge-ups.
Well, Coach K
and the Supercuts all-stars
kicked they fresh asses
repeatedly.
No wonder Jalen Rose
was salty about it.
JALEN ROSE: Schools like Duke
didn't recruit players like me.
I feel like they only
recruited Black players
that were Uncle Toms.
Too far, Jalen.
But to be fair, it seemed to me
that the press wasn't just
rooting for Duke,
they were standing up for them
along the way.
CBS REPORTER:
I'm sure that the UNLV players
are gaining some respect
for the courage
of the Duke players as well.
CBS REPORTER 2:
Neither team backing away,
and that's an important thing
to consider
when you're playing Georgetown.
They play you tough
and physical,
and the only way is
to look 'em straight in the eye
and say,
"We'll play that way too."
I mean, that's just
the way it is athletically.
I don't think anybody
should make any great, big
headline deal out of it.
BOB COSTAS: The Fab Five
against America's finest,
coming up next.
America's finest?!
Who are they, the Durham PD?
Now, remember.
At this point,
a lot of folks loved Duke
as much as they hated hip hop,
which was taking over
everywhere,
except college basketball.
Until now, this was
the closest rap had gotten
to college ball.
♪ 'Cause it's basketball
Mr. Kurtis Blow ♪
♪ They're playing basketball ♪
♪ We love that basketball ♪
But some of those
iconic Black teams
started bringing the culture
right onto the basketball court
with 'em.
But not Duke.
Coach K's kids
didn't break it down,
break beats, or breakdance.
You'd scratch a record
at Danny Ferry's house,
and you'd owe him
a new Toto album,
which is the closest
Africa got to Duke
until Luol Deng showed up.
Either way,
Coach K was claiming,
"All I do is win"
way before DJ Khaled.
And yeah,
Duke had a down year in 1995.
But that got Coach K
to recruit outside of his usual
young Republicans.
He brought in some of the most
talented teams he ever had,
and they got really good again.
But then, in 1999,
for the first time ever at Duke,
those guys left school early
and took all their swag
with them to the NBA.
In 2006, Coach K had figured out
how to go from Steve Urkel
to Stefan Urquelle.
He became the coach
of USA Basketball.
That got
all the cool kid's attention.
LEBRON JAMES:
You know, I love Coach K.
I love playing for him,
I love talking to him
on off days
and during practices.
And, you know,
I've been blessed,
with me not having
the ability to go to college
coming straight
out of high school,
to have a college coach.
LeBron said he didn't have
the ability to go to college
like he couldn't read
or something.
Not because he was
too smart to pass up
a 90-million-dollar Nike deal.
Anyway, the point is that
the kids who didn't know nothing
about no Christian Laettner
knew about players on Team USA,
like Kobe, Kevin Durant,
and LeBron James.
And now, somehow,
the name Mike Krzyzewski
rings out in the streets
like Nicky Barnes.
DUKE PLAYER: Coach K get love
in the streets.
So it don't matter
if we in Manhattan or Harlem,
they know Coach K, man.
It's crazy.
Think about how crazy that is.
In the '80s, parents from Duke
wouldn't let their kids
get within 40 acres of Harlem.
Now, this team looks like
the kids who sell you candy
on the train.
The all-academic Duke team
that everybody talked about
was full of one-and-doners.
But it's funny.
Hardly anyone called
Krzyzewski a hypocrite.
'Cause when he did it,
that was just the game
because he was the game.
Are you a supported
of this one-and-done rule?
It doesn't make any difference
if you're supportive of it.
We have no control over it.
What you have to do,
like you have to do in business,
is adapt.
And adapt he did.
Because Black culture
did eventually take over
college basketball.
But I'll be honest,
college basketball was better
when Duke was the official team
of white America.
Every game felt like
one of those episodes
of Family Feud.
Think about basketball
like the name Tyrone.
After a while, white folks just
let us keep it for ourselves.
But you know some folks
won't let us have nothing.
And for four decades,
a lot of fans felt like
Coach K was the one person
who just couldn't let us have
this one thing.
It all felt, like, personal,
even if it wasn't.
So believe me when I say,
sincerely,
happy retirement, Coach K.
No one has been wishing
for this day longer than us.
So to commemorate
the real legacy of Coach K,
we decided to give him
his very own museum exhibit.
Check it out.
To help the Black community
process Coach K's 42-year
reign of terror,
we opened The Boys in Blue:
Coach K's March Across America,
an exhibit at the
Schomburg Center for Research
in Black Culture in Harlem.
All day,
we led the public on tours
through our many exhibits,
highlighting Coach K's
destruction of our beautiful
Black college basketball teams.
This section of the exhibit
is called Trail of Sneers.
Look at this picture right now.
What do you see?
A coach talking to a ref
or a Karen talking to a cop?
Same vibes.
Sir, I see you.
I see your face is scrunching.
You've seen these faces before.
-And were they
bringing you good news?
-Never.
-Were they
bringing you positivity?
-Never.
-Were they uplifting you?
I want you to look at this one
right here.
What do you get when you look
at this picture?
A lot of anger in his eyes.
How he feels about himself
and others.
-So you see self-hate.
-Mm-hmm.
The anger's coming from within.
-That man right there
stole my dreams.
-Talk to me.
I used to play
high school basketball
with Jamal Mashburn,
and I lost to him.
-Are you still friends
with Jamal Mashburn?
-MUSEUMGOER: Absolutely.
-Is he still troubled
by what happened?
-Absolutely.
If you could express
your feelings about Coach K
in one word,
what would that word be?
-Terror.
-TOUR GUIDE: Terror?
I think that about sums it up.
Let's move on
to the next section, everybody.
JONES: He wasn't
the only one Coach K terrified.
Our exhibit also showcased
the nightmarish illustrations
the children of Detroit drew
after Duke defeated the Fab Five
in the 1992 NCAA
Championship game.
As a native
of Detroit, Michigan,
this is only giving me PTSD.
So you saw the game
that these kids saw?
-And I was that age.
-The city was down altogether.
I'm sure the water
got a little dirtier
after this defeat.
That's Flint.
My bad, my bad.
JONES: Dozens of artefacts
tell the stories of Black trauma
like Aminu Timberlake's jersey
that Christian Laettner
stomped on with his punk ass,
Coach K's single game salary,
and the salaries
of every Duke player
from 1980 to present,
and the embarrassing linchpins
to Coach K's success.
TOUR GUIDE: The next section
of the exhibit is called
The Wall of Unimpressive Whites.
It was these goofy
white athletes
that were out there
beating our amazing
Black college basketball teams.
And of course, Shelden Williams.
He is not white, but he is...
white by association.
Look at this guy! He looks
like Top Gun's co-pilot.
-What was his name?
-Goose.
TOUR GUIDE: Goose!
This Goose-looking motherfucker
beating all our teams.
And that's wrong!
-Y'all ready for
the next section of the exhibit?
-ALL: Yes.
I need some water. I'm ti--
I'm getting pissed off.
JONES: And I get it,
these corn-fed, cop calling,
cul-de-sac dwelling Caucasoids,
and Sheldon,
had shattered the dreams
of our heroes.
Thankfully, our
Alter of the NCAA Dead Homies
gave patrons a chance
to pay their respects.
Chris Webber,
that was my dude, man.
I had the--
I had the black socks.
Anybody-- Anybody have
the black socks?
-Y'all have the black socks?
-I had the black socks.
TOUR GUIDE:
Remember the black socks?
JONES: But their pain
was nothing compared to
what some have endured.
And now, we've reached the
Jalen Rose part of our exhibit.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Jalen Rose.
A true survivor of Coach K's
march across America.
I'm O-and-four against Coach K.
He beat me each time.
Even once after my uncle passed
and they came to Ann Arbor.
I had a patch on my jersey
and everything.
It still didn't matter.
This is not fiction.
This ain't no wax figure.
This a real one right here.
I once dribbled the ball across
half court against Bobby Hurley.
And he just fell for no reason,
and they called a charge.
Goddamn flopper.
Who's Bobby Hurley?
A miniature point guard
for the Duke Blue Devils.
Small man.
Are those really his shorts?
They are.
We wore extra baggy shorts.
Bobby Hurley chose
a kid's medium.
Too much thigh for my eye.
JONES: Damn right.
And we shouldn't allow ourselves
to be terrorized
by these creamy-thighed
OshKosh B'gosh Devils.
These Duke athletes
aren't monsters,
they're suckers led by
a five-foot ten-inch tyrant
that we, as a community,
have overcome.
Our day had come to an end,
but of course,
no Black history museum
would be complete
without a cool down area
to process our emotions.
Breathe in,
and return to the real world
with a renewed sense of self.
And always remember
that Coach K collected
over 40 years of victories,
but Danny Green
still put his balls
on Greg Paulus' forehead.
Keep hope alive.
♪ (PATRIOTIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪